patrick lober is a popular python
instructor and in this course he will
teach you how to train an artificial
intelligence to play a snake game using
reinforcement learning hey guys today i
have a very exciting project for you we
are going to build an ai that teaches
itself how to play snake and we will
build everything from scratch so we
start by creating the game with pygame
and then we build an agent and a deep
learning algorithm with pie torch i will
also teach you the basics of
reinforcement learning that we need to
understand how all of this works so i
think this is going to be pretty cool
and now before we start let me show you
the final project
so i can start the script by saying
python agents dot pi now this will start
training our agent
and here we see our game and then here i
also plot the scores and then the
average score
and now let me also start a stopwatch so
that you can see that all of this is
happening live
and now at this point our snake knows
absolutely nothing about the game it
only is aware of the environment and
tries to make some more or less random
moves but with each move and especially
with each game it learns more and more
and then knows how to play the game and
it should get better and better
so the first few games you won't see a
lot of improvements but don't worry
that's absolutely normal i can tell you
that it takes around 80 to 100 games
until our ai has a good game strategy
and this will take around 10 minutes
also you don't need a gpu for this so
all of this training can happen on this
cpu that's totally fine
okay so let me speed this up a little
bit
[Music]
[Music]
all right so now about 10 minutes have
passed and we are at about game 90 i
guess and now we can clearly see that
our snake knows what it should do so
it's more or less going straight for the
food and tries not to hit the boundaries
so it's not perfect at this point but we
can see that it's getting better and
better
so we also see that the average score
here is increasing and now the per the
best score so far is
and to be honest for me this is super
exciting so if you imagine that at the
beginning our snake didn't know anything
about the game and now with a little bit
of math behind the scenes it's clearly
following a strategy
so this is just super cool don't you
think all right so let me speed this up
a little bit more
[Music]
all right so after 12 minutes our snake
is getting better and better so i think
you can clearly see that our algorithm
works
so now let me stop this and then let's
start with the theory
so i will split the series into four
parts in this first video we learn a
little bit about the theory of
reinforcement learning in the second
part we implement the actual game or
also called the environment here with
pygame
then we implement the agent so i will
tell you what this means in a second and
in the last part we implement the actual
model with pytorch
so let's start with a little bit of
theory about reinforcement learning
so this is the definition from wikipedia
so reinforcement learning is an area of
machine learning concerned with how
software agents ought to take actions in
an environment in order to maximize the
notion of cumulative reward so this
might sound a little bit complicated so
in other words we can also say that
reinforcement learning is teaching a
software agent how to behave in an
environment by telling it how good it's
doing
so what we should remember here is that
we have an a chance so that's basically
our computer player then we have an
environment so this is our game in this
case
and then we give the agent a reward so
with this we tell it how good it's doing
and then based on their reward it should
try to find the best next action
so yeah that's reinforcement learning
and to train the agent there are a lot
of different approaches and not all of
them involve deep learning but in our
case we use deep learning and this is
also called steep q learning so this
approach extends reinforcement learning
by using a deep neural network to
predict the actions and that's we're
going to use in this tutorial
all right so let me show you the rough
overview of how i organized the code so
as i said we're having four parts so in
the next part we implement the game with
pie game then we implement the agent and
then we implement the model with pie
torch
so
our game has to be assigned such that we
have a game loop and then with each
game loop we do a play step
that gets an action
and then it does a step so it moves the
snake and then after the move it returns
the current reward and if we are game
over or not and then also the current
score
then we have the agent and the agent
basically puts everything together so
that's why it must know about the game
and it also knows about the model so we
store both both of them in our agent and
then we implement the training loop so
this is roughly what we have to do
so
based on the game we have to calculate a
state
and then based on the state we um
calculate the next action
and this involves calling model predict
and then with this new action
we do a next play step and then as i
said we get a reward the game overstate
and the score
and now with this information we
calculate a new state
and then we remember all of this so we
store the new state and the old state
and the game over state and the score
and with this we then train our model
so for the model i call this linear q
net so this is not too complicated this
is just a feed forward neural net
with a few linear layers and it needs to
have the these information so the new
state and the old state and then we can
train the model and we can call model
predict
and then this gets us the next action so
yeah this is
a rough overview how the code should
look like and now let's talk about some
of those variables in more detail for
example the action or the state or the
reward
so let's start with the reward so that's
pretty easy
so whenever our snake eats a food we
give it a plus 10 reward when we are
game over so when we die then we get -10
and for everything else we just stay at
zero so that's pretty simple
then we have the action so the action
determines our next move
so we could think that we have four
different actions so left right
up and down
but if we design it like this then for
example what can happen is if we go
right then we might take the action left
and then we immediately die so this is
basically a 180 degree turn
so we don't allow that so a better
approach to design the action is to only
use
three different numbers
and now this is dependent on the current
direction
so
um 1 zero zero means we stay in the
current direction so we go straight so
this means if we go right then we stay
right if we go left then we go left and
so on
then if we have 0 1 0 this means we do a
right turn and again this depends on the
current direction so if we go right and
do a right turn then we go
down next if we go down and do a right
turn again then we go left and then
again we would go up
so this is the right turn and the left
turn is the other way around so if we go
left and do a left turn then we go down
and so on so with this approach we
cannot do a 180 degree turn and we also
we only have to predict three different
states so this will make it a little bit
easier for our model
so now we have the reward and the action
then we also need to calculate the state
and the state means that we have to tell
our snake some information about the
game that it knows about so it needs to
know about the environment
and in this case our state has 11 values
so it has the information if the danger
is straight or if it's ahead if the
danger is right or if the danger is left
then it has um the current direction so
direction left right up and down
and then it has the information if the
food is left or right or up or down
and all of these are boolean values so
let me show you an actual example so in
this case
if we are going right and our food is
here
then we see um danger straight right and
left none of this is true
so
for example if our snake is over here at
this end and it's still going right
then danger straight would be a one
so this again also depends on the
current direction for example if we move
up at this corner here
then danger right would be a1
then for these directions only one of
them is one and the rest is always zero
so in this case we have danger right set
to one
and then for this in our case our food
is right of the snake and also down of
the snake so food right is one and food
down as one all right so now with the
state and the action we can design our
model so this is just a feed forward
neural net with an input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer and for the
input it gets the state so as i said we
have 11 different numbers in our state
11 different boolean values zero or one
so we need this size 11 at the beginning
then we can choose a hidden um size
and for the output we need three outputs
because then we predict the action so
this can be some numbers
and these don't need to be probabilities
so here we can have raw numbers and then
we simply choose the maximum so for
example if we
take 1 0 zero and if we go back then we
see this would be the action straight so
keep the current direction
so yeah that's how our model looks like
and of course now we have to train the
model
so for this let's talk a little bit
about this deep q learning
so q
stands for this is the q value and this
stands for the quality of the action
so this is what we want to improve so
each actions should improve the quality
of the snake
so we start by initializing the q value
so in this case we initialize our model
with some random parameters
then we choose an action by calling
model predict state and we also
sometimes choose a random move so we do
this especially at the beginning when we
don't know a lot about the game yet
so
and then later we have to do a trade-off
when we don't want to do a random move
anymore and only call model predict
and this is also called a trade-off
between exploration and exploitation
so this will get clearer later when we
do the actual coding
so then with this new action we perform
this action so we perform the next move
and then we measure the reward and with
this information we can update our q
value and then train the model and then
we repeat this step so this is an
iterative
training loop so now to train the model
as always we need to have some kind of
loss function that we want to optimize
or minimize so for the loss function we
have to look at a little bit of math and
for this i want to present you the
so-called belmont equation
so this might look scary so don't be
scared here i will explain everything
and actually it's not that difficult
when we um understand this and then code
this later
so
what we want to do here we need to
update the q value as i said here so
according to the belmont equation the
new q value is calculated like this so
we have the current q value
plus the
learning rate and then we have the
reward for taking that action at that
state
plus a gamma parameter which is called
this count rate so don't worry about
this i will also show this later in the
code again
and then we take the maximum expected
future reward
given the new state and all possible
actions at that new state
so
yeah this looks scary but i will
simplify that for you and then it's
actually not that difficult
so the old q value is model predict with
state 0
so if we go back at
this overview so the first time we say
get state from the game this is our
state 0
and then after we took this place step
we again measure or calculate the next
state so this is then our state one
so with this information again our first
queue is
just model predict with the old state
and then the new queue is the reward
plus our gamma value
times the maximum value of the
q state so again this is model predict
but this time we take state one
and then with these two information our
loss is simply
the q new minus q squared
and yeah this is nothing else than the
mean squared error so that's a very
simple error that we should already know
about and then this is what we must use
in our optimization
so yeah that's what we are going to use
so we have to
implement all of these three classes
and in the next video we start by
implementing the game
in the last part i showed you all the
necessary theory that we need to know to
get started with deep q learning
and now we start implementing all of the
parts so as i said we need to have a
game so the environment then we need an
agent and we need a model
so in this part we start by implementing
the game and we use pytorch for this
so
let me actually start by creating a
environment and we install all the
necessary dependencies that we need
so in this case i use conda to manage
the environments and if you don't know
how to use conda then i have a tutorial
for you that i will link here
but yeah if you don't want to use connor
you can also just use a normal virtual
and but i recommend to use a virtual and
and now let's create a virtual and with
conda create minus n and then give it a
name for example pi game n and i also
say i want python equals 3.7
all right so now this was created so now
we want to actuate it with conda
activate and then pie game n and hit
enter and then we see the name of the
environment in the front so this means
that we activated it successfully and
now we can start installing all what we
need so the first thing we want to
install is pie game for our game so pip
install pie game and hit enter
so this is done the next thing we need
is pytorch for our model later so for
this we can go to the official home page
and on install
and then here you can select your
operating system so i use mac
and i actually i want to say pip install
and we don't need cuda support so only a
cpu is fine
and we don't need torch audio because we
don't work with audio files so we can
only grab this pip install torch torch
vision
and then paste it in here and hit enter
and now this installs pytorch and all
the dependencies
all right so this is done and then we
need two more things for plotting later
so for this i say pip install
much plot lip and we also want i python
and then hit enter
all right so this was successful as well
and now we have everything we need so
now we can start implementing all the
codes and as a starting point i want to
grab the code from another tutorial that
i did so you can find this on github and
then on my um account and then in the
repo python fun
and here i actually have two snake games
so and then we need this one snake pie
game
and download this so you can do this and
i already did this and have this here so
if we open up the
editor here i'm visuals using visual
studio code
then we can see we have exactly those
two files
and
then um the first thing i want to do is
i want to run this file and test if this
is actually working
so right now this is just a normal
snake game that you have to control
yourself so you have to
use the arrow keys so let's say python
snake game dot pi and then let's hope
that this is working so yeah so now i
can control the snake
and i hope that i can eat the food yes
and now if i hit the boundary then we
are game over
so this is working our environment is
set up and now we can start implementing
our code so we can change this so that
we can use this as a
ai controlled game
so let me show you the overview from
last time so last time i told you that
we need a play step in our game and this
gets an action and based on this action
we then take a move and then we must
return a reward the game over state and
the current score
so
first let's
write down all the things that we need
to change here
so first we want to have a reset
function so after each
um game our agent should be able to
reset the game and start with a new game
then we need to
implement the reward that our agent gets
then we need to change the play function
so that it takes takes an action and
then um
returns a or
computes the direction
then we also want to keep track of the
current frame or let's call this
game
iteration
and for later we also need to have a
change in the if is collision function
to check if this is a collision
so
first let's
let me go over this code quickly so what
we do here is we use pi game
then for the direction we use an enum
then for the point we use a named tuple
and then here i created a class snake
game and here we initialize the things
we need for the game
so here we initialize the game state for
example for the snake we use a
list with
three initial values
and the head is always the front of this
list
then we keep track of the score and here
we have a helper function to place the
food
and yeah and we already
have a function that is called play step
and then if we go down to the very end
so here we have our
game loop so while this is true we take
a game or a play step
and we get the game over state and the
score so this place the function is the
most important one so here first we
right now we grab the user input so the
key we press
then we calculate a move based on this
key
and then we update our snake and check
if we are game over and
if we can continue we place the new food
or check if we eat the food
and we update our ui with this
helper function update ui then here we
have this helper function is collision
where we check if we either hit the
boundary or we run into ourself
and then we also have this helper
function move where we get the current
direction and then based on this
direction we simply um calculate
calculate the new position of the new
hat
so yeah that's all um
what is done here and now let's change a
few things though so the first one i
want to change the class name to say
snake game ai to make it clear that this
is a agent controlled game
and now so the first thing we want is
the reset functionality so in here um i
already have this comment where we in it
the game state so now we want to
refactor all of this into a
reset function so we create a new
function define
and then let's call this reset and it
only gets self and no other arguments
and here we can grab all of this code
and then simply paste it in here
and in our
initializer we then call self dot reset
so this is the first thing we need
additionally we want to keep track of
the um
game iteration or frame iteration so
let's call this self dot frame
iteration
and in the beginning this is just zero
then this define place food can stay as
it is and now we need to change the play
step function so first of all
if we have a look at the overview
here i already told you that now we need
to give this the action from the agent
and we need to return a reward so let's
start by
um using this action parameter
and here we grab the user input so
actually right now we can get rid of
this so the only thing we still check if
we want to quit the game and now here um
we already
have this helper function where we move
in the current direction
so actually what we change here now this
move function doesn't get the direction
from the user input so now here it gets
the action and then we have to determine
the new direction
so we do this in a second but first
let's only change this and then here we
call the self.move
with the action
and then we update the head then we
check if we are game over or not and we
actually now we also need the reward so
we simply say reward equals zero
and let's go back to the slides from
last time so the reward is really simple
whenever we eat a food we say plus 10
when we lose or when we die then we say
our reward is -10 and for everything
else we just stay at zero
so we initialize the reward with zero
then if we have a collision and game
over then we say our
reward equals to -10 and we want to
return this as well so return the reward
game over and self.score
and here we check only if we have a
collision so here i actually want to do
another
check so if
nothing happens for a long time so if
our snake doesn't improve and doesn't
eat the food but also doesn't die then
we also want to check this
and if this happens for a too long time
then we also break here
so we can say or and then here we say if
self dot frame iteration
and if that this gets too large without
anything happening then we um stop here
so here i use this little formula if
this is greater than 100 times the
length of our snake so remember this is
a list
then we break so this is also like this
then it's dependent on the
length of the snake
so the longer our snake is the more time
it has
so but then if it gets larger than this
value then we break
and of course we have to
update the self.frame iteration and we
can simply do this here at the beginning
so for each
play step we say self dot frame
iteration plus
equals
1
and when we reset it then we reset it
back to zero
so this is here and then yeah if we stop
we have the reward -10
then here if our hat
hits the food then we eat the food so
our score increases and our reward is
set to plus 10
then we place a new food and say
otherwise we remove the last part so we
simply move here
then this can stay as it is the update
function and at the very end we also
want to return the reward then
for the is collision function we need a
slight change so here i only check for
self.head but later um to calculate the
state or the danger which i told you
about so if we
have a look at the
state so here we calculate the
danger so if we are for example if we
are here at the corner then we have a
danger at the right
so for this it might be handy if we
don't use self.head inside here
but if we give this function a point so
this gets the point argument and let's
say by default this is none
and then here we simply ch check if the
point is
none then we set the point equals to
self dot head
so inside this where we call this with
no argument it can stay as it is
and then here of course we have to
change self.head to this is now our
point so here if we hit the
corner
point here and point here and point
here
then we have a collision and here if our
point is in the snake body then we also
have a collision
and otherwise we don't have a collision
all right so the update ui function can
stay like this
and now for the move function here we
need to change something so now we get a
action and now based on this action we
want to determine the next move
so if we go back to the slides so here
we designed the action like this so it
has three values
um one zero zero means we keep the
current direction and go straight 0 1 0
means we do a right turn and 0 0 1 means
we do a left turn
so this is dependent on the current
direction so if we go right and do a
right turn then we go down next if we go
down and do a right turn then we go left
next and so on and left turn is the
other way around
so now um we want to determine the
direction based on the action so let's
write a quick comment here we
have straight right turn or left turn so
to get the next direction first i want
to
define all the possible directions in a
clockwise order so we say clockwise
equals and then a list and here we start
with direction dot right so
here remember for the direction we use
this enum class
so it has to be one of those directions
so
our
clockwise directions should start with
direction right then from this on the
next one is
direction dot down
then we have direction dot
left and as last thing we have direction
dot up so right down left up this is
clockwise and then to get the current
direction or the current index of the
current direction we say index equals
and then we can say clockwise dot index
and then the index of the self dot
direction so we are sure that this has
to be in this array we because the self
direction
must be one of those enum values
and then we check that different um
possible states so these ones
so for this we can use numpy and i guess
we have to import numpy first as np
and then we can use it
here we can say if
numpy and then we use this function
array equal and then here we put in the
action and the array that we want to
compare
so if this is equal to
one zero zero
then we go straight or we keep the
current directions so we simply say
our new
direction
equals and then clockwise
of the
index and then remember the index is
just the index of the current direction
so here we basically have no
change then we say
l if if our
array if numpy array equal if the action
equals to 0 one zero then we do a
right turn
so this means we go clockwise so if we
go right then the next direction would
be down if we go down then the next
direction would be left and if we go
left then the next
direction would be up so here we say
index
equals or this is our next
index actually and here we say
this is the current index plus
1 but then modulo 4 so this means if we
are at the end up and then do the next
one if we have index
so this is index 0 1 2 3 and then if we
have index
4 modulo 4 is actually again index
zero again so from this we do a turn and
then come back at the front again
so this is our right turn so now this is
the
next index and now our new direction is
clockwise of the
next
index
and then otherwise we can simply use
else here and actually change this to an
l if so now this is the last case so it
has to be here it has to be
zero zero one
and if this is the case then let's copy
and paste this in here then our next
index is the current index
minus one modulo four
so this actually means we go
counter clockwise so we do a
left turn so if we start with right then
the next move would be up and then the
next would be
left and then the next would be down
and then right again and so on so now
this is our new direction and then
simply we say self direction
equals new
direction
and then we go on so here we extract the
head
and then here we have to check if self
dot's direction now is right then we
increase the position of x
and so on if we um have the left
direction then we decrease x
and if we go down then we actually
increase y so for
so the y starts at the top at zero and
then increases if we go down so if we go
down then we have to increase y and if
we go up then we have to decrease y so
if self direction equals up
then y minus equals the block size and
by the way the block size is just here a
constant value of 10 so that's how big
our one block of the snake should be in
pixels
so yeah this is everything we need here
in the move function and now here
we don't need this anymore so
this is actually no longer working with
a user input so you can just
delete this and then later we control
this class from the agent
and call this play step function
so yeah for now this is all we need to
implement the game
so i already talked about the theory of
deep q learning in the first part
in the last part we implemented the pi
game so that we can use it in our
agent controlled environment and
now we need the agent so let's start and
so here um if you haven't watched the
first two parts then i highly recommend
to do so
so this is the starting point from last
time and i actually want to make one
more change that i forgot
so
here the is collision function should
actually be public because then our
agent should use it
so just remove the underscore here and
then also remove it in this class itself
when we call this
so then we have our snake game and i
also want to rename this to just be game
and now we create a new file agent dot
pi and then start implementing this
so first here we import torch from pi
torch
then we import random because when later
we need this then we also need
import numpy snp
and from our um implemented class we
need the snake game so we say from
game import snake
like snake game a i
so i think that's what we call this
class snake game a
i
so yeah that's the right name then we
also hear at the beginning we defined
this enum for the direction and this
named tuple for the point which has an x
and a y attribute
so we also want to import these two um
things so we import direction and we
import point and then we also say from
collections
we want to import deck so this is a data
structure where we want to store our
memories so
um if you don't know what a deck is then
i will put a link in the description
below
so this is really handy in this case and
you will see why this is the case later
and then here i want to define some
parameters as constants so we have a
maximum memory of let's say 100
000
so we can store 100 000 items in this
memory
then we also want to to use a batch size
that you will see later and here i will
set this to 1000 so you can play around
with these parameters
and i also want a learning rate later
and i want to set this to 0 0 1
and yeah feel free to change this and
then we start creating our class agent
and it gets of course an init function
with self and no other
arguments and then let's have a look at
the slides from the first part where i
explained the training
so we want to create a training function
where we do all of this so we need to
get the state calculate the state
where we are aware of the current
environment then we need to calculate
the next move from the state
and we need to
um then we want to update or do the next
step and call game.playstep and then
calculate the new state again then we
want to store everything in memory and
then we also want to train our model so
we need to store the game and the model
in this class
so first of all let me create the
functions that we need first so we need
a function get state which gets self and
this this gets the game
and then we calculate the state that i
showed you with these 11 different
variables then we want to have a
function that we call remember
remember and it has self and here we
want to put in the state then the action
then we want to remember the reward for
this action and we want to calculate or
we want to store the next state
next state
and we also want to store done or bit or
you can also call this game over so this
is the current game overstate then we
need two different functions to train
and we call this defined train
on the long memory and it only needs
self so i will explain this later
and we also let's copy and paste this i
also have a function define train on
short memory so this is only with one
step
you will see this later
then we need a function and we call this
get action to get the action based on
the state so it gets self and the state
and first we only say pass
and these are all the functions we need
i guess and then i want to have a global
function that i call simply train
and here we say pass and then when we
start this module h and dot pi so we say
if name
underscore equals equals
main then we simply call this train
function and then we can start the
script by saying python agent dot pi
like i did in the very first tutorial so
let's start implementing the agent and
the training function so let's start
with the init function of the agent so
here what i want to store is first i
want to store some more parameters so
self.number of games so i want to keep
track of this so this is zero in the
beginning
then self.epsilon
equals um zero in the beginning this is
a parameter to control the
randomness so you will see this later
then we also need self dot gamma equals
zero
so this is
this is the so-called this count rate
which i briefly showed in the first
tutorial i will explain this a little
bit more in the next tutorial where we
implement the model and the actual deep
q learning algorithm then we want to
have a memory so we say
self.memory equals and for this we use
this stack and this can have a argument
max leng equals
and here we say max memory
and what then happens if we exceed this
memory then it will automatically remove
elements from the left so then it will
call pop left for us and that's why this
deck is really handy here
and then later here we also want to have
our model and the trainer so i will
leave this for a or s to do for the last
part in the next video and now this is
all for the init function and now we can
go back and now let's do the training
function next so again let's have a look
at these slides so we need
these
functions in this order
so
let's first let's write some comments
of first let's create some lists to keep
track of the scores so this is an empty
list in the beginning and this is used
for plotting later
so then we also want to keep track of
the mean scores or average scores this
is also an empty list in the beginning
then our total score equals zero in the
beginning
our record our best score is zero in the
beginning
then we set up a agent so agent equals
an agent
and we also need to create a game so the
game is a snake game ai object
and then here we create our training
loop so we say while true so this should
basically run forever until we quit the
script
and now here let's write some comments
so we want to get
get the old state or the current state
so here let's say state old equals and
then we call agent dot
get states and this gets the game so we
already
set this up correctly we only have to
implement it then
then after this we want to get the move
based on this current state
so we say the final move equals agent
dot
get
action so we actually called this action
and the action is based on the state
then with this move we want to perform
the move and then and get new state so
for this we say
reward um
done and score
equals and here we call game dot play
step from last time
so
i think
game dot play step with the action yes
game dot play step and this gets the
final move
and then we get the state
old or the new now the new state state
new
state new equals agent and again gets
state now with the new game
then after that we want to train the
short memory of the agent so only for
one step
so
for this we say agent agent dot train
short memory
and this gets if we have a look here um
actually uh this short memory should get
some parameters so exactly the same as
we put in the remember function so train
short memory gets all of those variables
and then here when we call this now we
should get some hints strain
or let's
save this file and then say agent dot
train short memory and now we should get
the hints no we don't get this but
actually we want to have the
state action reward next state and done
so here let's do this so say let's say
state old then the action which was the
final move then the reward
then the state new and adds last thing
the done or game over state variable so
now we have this then we want to
remember all of these and store this in
the memory so we say agent dot remember
and then here it gets the same
um variables so we want to store all of
this in our deck and
then this is all we need so now we check
if
done or if game over then if this is
true
then what we want to do is um
we want to let's write a comment train
the long memory and this is also called
replay memory or experience replay and
this is very important for our agent so
now it trains again on all the previous
moves and games that it played
and this tremendously helps him to
improve itself
and we also here want to plot the
results so first of all we want to reset
the game so we can simply do this by
saying game dot reset we already have
this function
here so this initializes the game state
and resets everything so the score the
snake the frame iteration and places the
initial snake and the food
so now we have this then we want to
increase agents dot number of games so
this
plus equals one
then we want to say agent dot train long
memory and this doesn't need any
arguments then we want to check if we
have a new high score so if score
greater than the current record then we
say record equals our new score
and we will also want to leave this as a
to do here so here we want to say agent
dot model
dot save later when we have the model
and so here in the here we want to store
this as self.model
and now what we also want to do here um
let's print some information so print
the
game and then the current number and
then the score and the record
so here let's say our game is agent dot
n
games
then we also want to plot the or print
the score so this is just the score
and we want to print the current record
so the record equals record
and then here we want to do some
plotting so i will implement this in the
next tutorial so i will leave this s8 to
do
so this is all for our training function
so what i showed in the slides
and now of course we have to implement
those functions
so for the
get
state function um let's go back to this
overview
and here as i said we store 11 values so
if the danger is
straight right or left then the current
direction so only one of these is one
and then the position of the food if
it's left of the snake right of the
snake up or down of the snake
so these are the 11 states and now let
me actually copy and paste the code in
here so that i don't make any
mistakes
but we will go over this
so first let's grab the head from this
game so we can do this by calling game
dot snake zero so this is a list and the
first item is our head
then um let's create some points
next to this head in all directions that
we need to check if this hits the
boundary and if this is a danger
so for this we can use this named tuple
so we can create a point
with this location but minus 20 so the
20 is hard coded here so this is the
number that i used for the block size
so like this we create four points
around the head then the current
direction is simply a boolean where we
check if the current game direction
equals to one of those
so only one of those is one and the
other one is
zero or false
and then
um we create this
array or this list with this 11 um
states so
here we check
that if the danger is straight or ahead
and this is dependent on the current
direction so if we are going right
and the point right of us gives us a
collision
then we have a danger the same or or if
we go left and our
left point gets a collision then we also
have a danger here and so on so this is
dangerous straight and then danger right
means if we go up
and the point right of us would give a
collision then we have a danger for a
right turn basically
and so on and the same for the left so
this might be a little bit tricky so i
recommend that you pause here and go
over this logic for yourself again
so yeah these only have give us three
values in our state so far
then we have the move direction where
only one of them is true and the other
one is false
and for the food location we simply
check if food if game food x is
smaller than game head x then we have
food is left of us
and the same way we check for right up
and down and then we convert our list to
a numpy array and say the data type is
in so this is a nice little trick to
convert this true or false booleans to a
zero or one
so yeah now this is the get state method
now let's move on to the remember
function so here we want to remember all
of this in our memory so this is a deck
and this is very simple so here we say
self dot memory and then the deck has
also the append function where we want
to append all of this
in this order so the state the action
the reward the next state and the game
over state
and as i said if this exceeds the
maximum memory
then pop left if
max
mem
memory is
reached and yeah this is the remember
function
then let's start implementing the train
long and short memory functions so for
this so we actually we store a model and
a trainer in here so let's actually say
self dot
model equals let's say this is only none
in the beginning and leave a to do
and self dot trainer equals none in the
beginning and this is a to do
so these are objects that we create in
the next tutorial
and then here
we call this trainer to actually do the
optimization
so let's start here so for only one step
we say
self.trainer and then this should get a
function that we call let's call this
train step
and then it gets all of these variables
so the state the action the reward the
next state and the game overstate and
this is all that we need to train it for
only one game step
and we design this function um so that
it takes either only one state like this
but it can also take a whole tensor or a
numpy array and then uses multiple as a
so-called batch so let's do this here so
for this we take the variables from our
memory
so here we want to grab a batch and so
in the beginning we defined the batch
size is 1 000 so we want to grab 1 000
samples from our memory
but first we check if we um already have
a thousand samples in our memory
so we say if lang and self dot memory if
this is
smaller
then the batch size then we simply
or actually let's say if this is greater
so if this is greater than we want to
have a random sample and say
mini
sample equals and then we want to get a
random sample so we can use random dot
sample so we already imported the random
module
random dot sample from self dot
memory and as a size it should have the
batch size
so this will return a list of tuples and
this is because here i forgot one
important thing so when we want to store
this and append this we want to append
this as only one element so only one
tuple so we need extra parenthesis here
so this is one tuple that we store
and then here we get
the batch size number of tuples
and otherwise else if we don't have uh
a thousand elements yet then we simply
take the whole memory so we say mini
sample equals self dot
memory and
then we again want to call this training
step and for this so let's call this
here again self.trainer.trainstep
but here we have
multiple states so let's call this
states actions rewards next states and
done
and right now so now we have it in
this format that we have one
tuple after another
and now we want to extract this from the
mini sample and then put every states
together every action together every
reward to it together and so on and this
is actually a really simple with python
so we can say we want to extract the
states the actions
the rewards the next
states and the
duns game overs
and here we simply use the built in sip
function and have to use one asterisk
and then the mini sample argument
so yeah check that for yourself if you
don't know how the sip function works
but again it now it puts every states
together every actions and so on if this
is too complicated for you then you can
also just do a for loop so you can
iterate over this mini sample and
basically say for
action
or for state
action
rewards
next state and done in one mini sample
and then again you call
this here for only one for only one
argument so yeah you can do it both ways
but actually i recommend to do it this
way because then you have this as only
one argument and then you can do this
faster in pytorch all right so now we
have both the training functions now we
only need the get action function so
here in the beginning we want to do some
random moves and this is also called a
trade-off between
exploration and
exploitation in deep learning so at some
point or in the beginning one we want to
make sure that we also make random moves
and explore the environment but then the
better our
model or our agent gets the less random
moves we want to have and the more we
want to exploit our agent or our model
so
yeah this is what we want to do here so
for this we use this
epsilon parameter that we
initialized in the beginning
so for this let's implement this first
so we say self dot epsilon equals and
this is dependent on the number of games
so here i hard code this to 80 minus
self dot number of games you can play
around with this and then let's get the
final move so in the beginning
we say zero zero zero and then one of
those now has to be true
so here first let's check if random dot
rent int and here between 0 and 200
if this is smaller than self dot epsilon
then we take a random move so we say
move equals
random dot rant ins and this must be
between 0 and 2 so the 2 is actually
included here and this will give us a
random
value 0 1 or 2 and now this index must
be set to one so we say final move of
this
move index equals one
and yeah so so the more games we have
the smaller our epsilon will get
and the smaller the epsilon will get
the less frequent this will be
less than the epsilon
and when this is even this can even
become negative and then we don't longer
have a random move so again if this was
too fast here then feel free to pause
and think about this logic again
so now we have that and otherwise else
so here we actually here we want to do a
move that is based on our model so we
want to get a prediction prediction
equals self dot model dot predict and it
wants to predict the action based on one
state so we call the state zero
and we get this here but we want to
convert this to a tensor so we say state
0
equals torch dot tensor and as an input
it gets the state
and we also give it a data type equals
let's use a torch dot float here then we
call self.model predict with the state
this will give us a prediction and this
can be a raw value so if we go
back to this slide
so this can be a raw value and then we
take the maximum of this and set this
index to a1
so here we say our move equals and we
get this by saying torch arc max and the
arc max of the prediction and this is a
tensor again and to convert this to only
one number we can call the item and now
this is an integer and now again we can
say final move of the smooth index is
one
and now we have this so now we return
the final move here
return
and yeah this is all we need so now we
have this and can save it like this
and now we have all that we need for our
agent class and now in the next one
so what we must do here is implement the
model and the trainer and then also the
plotting
so let's go back to the code and here i
left this essay to do so we need a model
and a trainer
so let's create a new file and let's
call this model dot pi
and then here let's first import all the
things we need so we need import torch
then we want to import torch dot n n s n
n
then we want to import torch dot optim s
optim and also import torch
dot n n dot functional s capital f
and we also want to import o s to save
our model
and now we want to implement two classes
one for the model and one for the
trainer so let's create a class and
let's call this linear underscore
qnet and this has to inherit from nn dot
module
module
and by the way if you are not
comfortable with pytorch and want to
learn how to use this framework then i
have a beginner series here on this
tutorial for free and i will put the
link in the description so this will
teach you everything to need to get
started with pytorch
so
right now let's start implementing this
linear qnet function so we need the init
function define init and we need to have
self
and this gets an input size
input size a
hidden size and an output size
and then the first thing we want to do
is to call this super initializer so we
call super in it
and here um this is very simple so if we
have a look at the slides
then our models should just be a feed
forward neural net with a input layer a
hidden layer and an output layer
um feel free to extend this and improve
this but it works fine for this case and
it's actually not that bad here
so let's create two linear layers so
let's call this self.linear1
equals nn.linear
and this gets the input size as an input
and then the hidden size as the output
size
then we have self.linear2
equals
nn.linear and now this gets the hidden
size as the input and the output size as
the output then as always in pi torch we
have to implement the forward function
with self and it gets x so the tensor
and here what we want to do is first we
want to apply the linear layer and we
also use an actuation function here so
again if you don't know what this is
then check out my beginner tutorial
series there i explain all of this so we
say x and then we can call f dot
reloose we use this directly from the
functional module
and here we say self dot linear one with
our tensor x as the input so first we do
the linear layer then we apply the
actuation function
and then again we apply the second layer
so we call self dot linear 2 with x
and we don't need an actuation function
here at the end we can simply use the
raw numbers and return x
so this is our forward function
then let's also implement a helper
function to save the model later so
let's call this self
safe and this gets the file name as an
input and i use a default here
so we say model dot pth is simply the
file name and then the last time i think
i already
called this function um so not yet but
now we can comment this out so if we
have a new high score then we call agent
dot model dot save and here let's create
a new
folder in here so let's say this is the
model folder path equals and let's
create a new folder
in the current directory and call this
model so dot slash model and then we
check if this already exists so the file
in this folder
so we can say if not os dot path dot
exists and then we say our
model folder path
then we create this so we say os dot
makers and we want to make this model
folder path
then we create this final file name so
we say file
name equals os
dot path dot join and we want to join
the model folder path and the file name
that we use here as the input now this
is the file name for saving and then we
want to
save this and we can do this with torch
dot save and we want to save self dot
state
dict so i also have a tutorial about
saving the model we only need to save
this state dictionary
and then as a path we use this file name
so now this is all we need for our
linear q net
and now to do the actual training and
optimization we also do this in a class
that i call q
trainer q trainer
and now here what we want to do we want
to implement a init function
which gets self then it also gets the
model then it should get a learning rate
and it should get a gamma parameter
and here we simply store everything
self.lr equals lr self dot gamma equals
gamma
and we also store the model so we say
self dot model equals model
then to do a pie charge optimization
step we need a optimizer so we can
create this by calling self.optim
or let's call this optimizer
equals and we get this from the opt-in
module and here you can choose one
optimizer so i use the atom optimizer
and we want to optimize model.parameters
and this is a function
and then it also needs the learning rate
so lr equals self dot l r
and now we also need a
criterion or a loss function so let's
call this self dot criterion
equals and now if we go back to these
slides at the very end
we learned in the first part that this
is nothing else than the mean squared
error so that's very simple
so we can create this here by saying
self.criterion equals so this is nn.mse
loss and now this is what we need in our
initializer and then we also need to
define a
we call this train step function which
gets self
and then it needs to have all the stored
um parameters from last time
so it needs to have or let's have a look
at
this
so here when we call this it needs the
state the final move the reward the new
states and done
so let's copy and paste this in here and
rename this slightly so this is just the
state
this is the action this is the reward
so this is the new state this can
uh let's call this
next state here and then done can stay
as it is
and for now let's simply do
pass here and before we implement this
let's go back to the agent and now set
this up so here we say from
and we call this model and we want to
import the linear i think we call this
linear q
net and q
trainer
and then here
in the initializer we want to create an
instance of the model and of the trainer
so self.model equals our linear qnet and
now this needs the input size the hidden
size and the output size
so here i use 11 256 and three
so remember if we have a look at the
slides again
um
the first one is the size of the state
so this is 11 values and the output must
be three because and we have three
different
um
three different numbers in our action
and you can play around with this hidden
size but the other ones have to be
eleven and three
so this is the model and the trainer
equals the q trainer and this gets the
model so self.model then it gets the
learning rate equals the learning rate
which we specified here
and we also pass on the gamma value so
gamma equals self dot gamma and the
gamma is the discount rate so i this has
to be a value that is smaller than 1 and
usually this is around 0.8 or 0.9 so in
this case let's set this to 0.9
so you can play around with this as well
but keep in mind that it must be smaller
than one so now we have this and then i
made one error in the last tutorial so
this is very important that we fix this
right now
so here in the get
action function i actually
i called this self.model
predict but actually pythog doesn't have
a predict function so this would be the
api for tensorflow for example
so in pi torch we simply call self.model
like this
and then this will execute this forward
function so this is actually the
prediction then
so yeah
please make sure to fix this
okay so now we have everything and if we
have a look and go back then we see we
call this
self.trainer train step
with only one parameter but also with
multiple ones so we want to make sure
that we can handle different sizes
so now let's start implementing this
function and now the first thing we want
to do
so right now this can be um either a
tuple or a list or just a single value
so let's convert this to a pi torch
tensor so let me copy and paste this in
here so we do this for the states the
next state the action and reward
and we can do this by calling
torch.tensor
and then the variable and we specify the
data type to torch dot float
and we don't have to do this for the
done or game over value because we don't
need this as a tensor and now we want to
handle
multiple
sizes so we want to check if the length
and then we can
check
state dot shape
and if this is one then we only have one
dimension and then we want to reshape
this so right now we only have
if this is the case then we only have
one number
but actually we want to have it in the
form one and then the values so this is
the number
of um batches so if this is already
if this has
already multiple values then it's
already in the in the size n
and x
so then it's already correct
and now here we want to append one
dimension and we can do this with the
torch unsqueeze function so we can say
state equals states dot or sorry not
state but
torch dot un squeeze
squeeze and then the
states and we want to
put it in dimension
zero
or axis zero so this means that it
appends one dimension in the beginning
and this is then just one then i also
wanted to do this for the other um
tensors so for the next state and for
action and reward
and the done value we also want to
convert this right now this is only a
single value and we want to convert this
to a tuple so we can do it like this so
now we have a
done so this is how you define a tuple
with only one value
and now um we have it in the correct
shape so now what we have to implement
is um from last time or from the very
first tutorial where i showed this
bellman equation
and then we simplified this so we have
the old queue where we simply call model
predict with the old state
and the new queue with this formula so
let's do this so
first let's um write a comment here so
as first thing we want to
get the predicted
predicted q values with the current
state
and this is simply by doing let's call
this prediction equals self dot model
and then we want to do this with
state 0 or we just call this state here
and then for the second part we need
this formula the reward plus the gamma
value times the maximum of again model
predict with state one
so first let's write this as a new uh
comment so the first thing is we want to
apply this formula reward plus
gamma times and then
the next
predicted
q value
and
then we want to have the
maximum so the maximum of this so
maximum
and then um this is a little bit tricky
so the maximum of this um
sorry let's do it like this maximum of
next predicted q value so this is only
one value
but um if we do it like
as first
um parameter the predictions this has
actually this is the action this is
actually
three different values
so
what we do to get the same here is we do
a clone of this
and then we set the
index
with this action to the new q value so
this is let's call this q new like i
showed you in the formula
and then we set the
let's call this predictions and then the
index of
the
arc max of the action we set this to our
q
new value
so again this might be tricky so again
we want to calculate the new q value
with this formula that i showed you but
then we need to have it in the same
format and for this we simply clone this
so then we have three values again
and two of the values are the same but
the value with the
action so the action is for example
one zero zero
so um the index of the one is then set
to the new q value
so this is what we want to do here
so for this let's first let's create a
clone target
equals prediction dot clone so we can do
this with a pi torch tensor and then um
we want to iterate over our tensors and
apply this formula so for this we say
for
index in
range and then the length of the let's
call this done and here everything
should have the same size so
then this works so now we iterate over
this and then one thing that i didn't
mention so far is that we only only want
to do this only do this if not done
um otherwise we simply take the whole
reward so we say q new equals reward of
the current
current index and now we check if we are
not done so we say if
not
done and the done is of the current
index
then we apply this formula so now we say
q
new
is actually um the reward so the reward
of the current
index
plus
self dot
gamma
and then times torch dot
max the maximum value
of the next prediction so here's self
dot model of next
state of this
index
so this is exactly what we have written
here and now we need to set the
target of the maximum value of the
action to this value
so here we get the let's we call this
target so the target of the current
index and then of the arc max of the
action
so for this we can again say torch dot
arc max of the of the action and we want
to have this as a item so as a value and
not as a tensor and now this is our q
new value so this might be a little bit
tricky to understand so i recommend that
that you pause here and go over this
again
and now we have everything that we need
so let's have a look at the slides again
we have our q and our q
new
and then we apply the loss function so
the mean squared error and in pi torch
so what we have to do here we can simply
use this optimizer and do a step
and first we have to call this zero grad
function to empty the gradient so this
is just something that we have to
remember in pi torch
and then we calculate the loss by
calling
self dot criterion
and here we put in the
target and the prediction
so this is q new and q
and then we call loss dot backward and
apply back propagation and then update
our gradients and then we call
self.optimizer.step
and this is all that we need in this
training step and now this is actually
all that we need in this model file
so now again let's go back to the agent
and i guess we already set up the q
trainer
and then when we train this we call this
train step function
either for only one of those parameters
or for a whole batch and now this
function can handle different sizes
and now the only thing left to do here
is to actually to plot the results
so for this let's create a new file and
let's call this hell
helper dot pi
and then here let me actually copy and
paste this in here
so this is just a simple function with
matplotlib and i python
and yeah here we want to plot the scores
so this is a list and we want to plot in
the plot the mean score
so
let's create them so here in the agent
we say from
helper import the plot function
and then down here in the training
function so we already created an empty
list for the scores and for the mean
scores
and now after each um
game we want to append the score
so let's remove the to do and implement
this
so we say plot scores dot
appends and then the current score
then let's calculate the new mean or
average score
so for this let's say total score
plus equals the score
and then let's call this mean score
equals the total score divided by the
number of games so agent and games
and then we append this to plot mean
scores dot append
the mean score and then we simply call
the plot function with the plot scores
and then the plot
mean scores
and now let's save this file and also
let's save this file and then let's try
it out so in the terminal
let's call agent dot pi and let's cross
fingers
so
we have a syntax error in the model.pi
file
so um
here we
actually here we have two equal signs
so let's fix this and save this and run
it again
and then we made another mistake name
error so here this is actually called
prediction.clone so again let's save
this and run this
and now it starts training without
crashing and it also plots
so let's
let this run and see if this is
improving
[Music]
all right so as we can see the algorithm
works and the snake is getting better
and better and the scores are getting
higher and higher and also the mean or
average score is getting higher so i
forgot one
important thing which i show you in a
second
but for now um
so the snake is not perfect and the main
issues are that it traps itself
sometimes and also sometimes it gets
stuck in an endless loop sequence
so this is something that you can
improve as a homework so yeah like this
it now it trapped itself
so yeah let me
stop this actually and then show you
what i forgot so in the game we can
actually um set the speed
so for the
human controlled game when i want to
play this i set this to 20 but now i
recommend to set this to a larger number
so that the training will be faster
so for example you can use 40 here or
even higher so i go with 40 and yeah i
think that's the whole code you can also
find this on github and yeah i hope you
really enjoyed this little series about
reinforcement learning and if you
enjoyed this then please hit the like
button and consider subscribing to the
channel and then i hope to see you next
time bye